mark is real
real
[Music]
i'm here to tell you mark is is is
definitely
real i've seen him with my eyes in real
life
real mark is real i've known lixian okay
we're friends we're friends
we're friends i know lixian i cannot
imagine
what has driven him to say what he's
been saying about mark
to make that the funny video
i i don't know what happened okay i
don't know what's up with lexian
uh but that the video's a joke man
that video is not the truth the truth
is that mark is real okay i've i've i've
we've i've
touched i've touched him i've held his
hand i
definitely have hugged mark i've been to
his house i
we've slept we slept in the same room
for a whole year
he was above me and i was below him uh
not touching
he's real i played i played video games
with him i we talk
online mostly online we talk a lot
online
2020 was a long year and uh and and you
know
i i've seen a lot of people i haven't
seen a lot of my friends
but that doesn't mean they're not real i
know my friends are real
and mark is one of my friends which
means mark is real i've known him
for years i've known mark since 2007
went to college together
he didn't finish but we went there
together i know he went there there's
just
it's not funny anymore okay it's not
funny anymore
it's it's it's scaring me the number of
people who
who believe lithium's lies this is is
scaring me
it's too much and um we just this joke
needs to end
marcus real mark is the realest human
you could possibly imagine
you touch him and he squishes just like
other human if flesh people do
just come on he's he's real just you can
trust me look
look into my eyes you can trust me and
you you all just need to shut up
okay shut up and go away and stop
making the joke that mark's not real
because i know mark is real
i know what's real mark is real okay
that's it